merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer monsieur le ministre mardi 3
janvier dernier à Écully commune de ma
circonscription située sur la métropole
lyonnaise un homme a été tué au pied
d'une bâtiment abritant un centre social
une crèche et une école à l'heure de la
sortie des écoles
il sera certainement pas le dernier dans
tous l'Hexagone ces situations se
multiplient que ce soit à Marseille à
Nantes à Lyon ou même à Mayotte la
violence est quotidienne la politique de
la ville menée depuis 2014 laisse ses
quartiers gangrener par toutes sortes de
trafic à l'abandon et sans perspective
la déclassification des zones urbaines
sensibles en simple quartier politique
de la ville en 2015 a eu pour seul effet
de sortir plus de 800 quartiers
difficiles des radars on a simplement
caché la poussière sous le tapis
aujourd'hui les services de secours les
médecins et même les forces de l'ordre
sont reçus à coup de tir de mortier ou
de jettes parpaing les habitants de ces
quartiers ont besoin de vous en 2021 le
nombre de victimes par homicide était en
hausse tout comme celui des victimes des
causes et blessures volontaires quant
allez vous prendre la mesure de
l'exaspération des Français
l'état va-t-il décider de reconquérir
ces territoires abandonnés quand
allez-vous donner aux forces de l'ordre
les moyens légaux et matériels de
combattre les trafiquants je vous
remercie de votre réponse